Huxley, en una trivial.
Orwell temía que la verdad
nos sería ocultada,
y Huxley que seríamos ahogados
en un océano de irrelevancia.
En resumen, es escoger entre
el Gran hermano viéndote
y tu viendo al Gran Hermano.
(Risas)
Pero no tiene que ser así.
No somos consumidores pasivos
de datos y tecnología.
Decidimos el rol que juega en nuestra vida
y cómo le damos significado,
pero para hacerlo,
tenemos que poner mucha atención
desde cómo pensamos
hasta cómo codificamos.
Tenemos que hacer preguntas, preguntas difíciles,
para pasar de contar cosas
a entenderlas.
Estamos bombardeados constantemente por historias
de los muchos datos que hay en el mundo,
pero cuando se refiere a datos masivos,
y los retos de interpretarlos,
el tamaño no lo es todo.
También está la velocidad
a la que se mueven,
las muchas variantes de tipos de datos,
he aquí algunos ejemplos:
imágenes,
texto,
video,
audio.
Lo que une estos diferentes tipos de datos
es que son creados por gente
y requieren contextos.
Hay un grupo de científicos de datos
de la Universidad de Illinois-Chicago,
llamados Colaboración para la Salud en Medios,
trabajando con los Centros de
Control de Enfermedades
para entender mejor
cómo la gente habla sobre dejar de fumar,
cómo hablan de cigarros electrónicos,
y qué pueden hacer colectivamente
para ayudarse a dejarlo.
Lo interesante es que, si quieres entender
cómo la gente habla sobre dejar de fumar,
primero tienes que entender
a qué se refieren al decir "fumar".
En Twitter, hay 4 categorías principales:
la primera, fumar cigarros;
la segunda, fumar marihuana;
la tercera, ahumar costillas;
y la cuarta, chicas ardientes.
(Risas)
Entonces, tenemos que pensar,
¿cómo habla la gente de cigarros electrónicos?
Y hay tantas maneras diferentes
en las que la gente lo hace,
y se puede ver del lado de
es un tipo complejo de búsqueda.
Y lo que nos recuerda es que
el lenguaje es creado por la gente
y la gente es enrevesada y somos complejos
y usamos metáforas y argots y jergas
24 horas por 7 días a la semana.
en muchos idiomas.
Y luego de un momento a otro, cambiamos.
Así como estos anuncios que la CDC puso,
estos anuncios de TV que tenían mujeres
con un hoyo en las gargantas, muy gráficos
y perturbadores,
¿realmente tuvieron impacto
en que la gente dejara de fumar?
Colaboración para la Salud en Medios respeto los límites de sus datos,
pero fueron capaces de concluir
que esos anuncios —y los pueden haber visto—
tenían el efecto de llevar a las personas
hacia un proceso de pensamiento
que podía impactar su comportamiento futuro.
Lo que admiro y aprecio de este proyecto,
aparte del hecho, e incluyendo que
está basado en una necesidad humana real,
es que es un ejemplo fantástico de coraje
en medio de un océano de irrelevancia.
No son solo los datos masivos los que producen
retos de interpretación,
porque enfrentémoslo,
los humanos tenemos una historia muy rica
de tomar una cantidad de datos, no importa lo pequeña,
y arruinarlo.
Así, hace muchos años, quizá recuerden
que el antiguo presidente Ronald Reagan
fue muy criticado por una declaración
de que los hechos son cosas estúpidas.
Se le fue la lengua, seamos justos.
En realidad quería citar la defensa
de Jhon Adams
a los soldados británicos
en los juicios de la Masacre de Boston
de que los hechos son tozudos.
Pero creo que hay algo de sabiduría
accidental en lo que dijo
porque los hechos son tozudos,
pero a veces también son estúpidos.
Quiero contarles una historia personal
de porque esto importa tanto para mí.
Necesito tomar aire.
Mi hijo Isaac, cuando tenía 2 años,
fue diagnosticado con autismo,
y era este alegre, hilarante,
amoroso, y afectuoso niñito,
pero las métricas en sus evaluaciones
de desarrollo,
que ven cosas cómo el número de palabras
—en ese momento, ninguna—
gestos comunicativos y
poco contacto visual,
pusieron su nivel de desarrollo
en el de un bebé de nueve meses.
Y el diagnóstico estaba bien
según los hechos,
pero no contaba la historia completa.
Después de un año y medio,
cuando tenía aproximadamente cuatro,
lo encontré frente a la computadora un día
buscando mujeres en Google,
deletreado "m-i-j-e-r-e-s".
E hice lo que cualquier padre
obsesionado haría:
empezar a presionar el botón "atrás"
para ver que más había buscado.
Y estaban en orden: hombres,
escuela, autobús y computadora.
Estaba sorprendida,
porque no sabíamos que podía deletrear,
mucho menos leer, y le pregunte,
"Isaac, ¿cómo lo hiciste?"
Él me miró muy serio y dijo,
"Escribí en la cajita".
Estaba enseñándose a sí mismo
a comunicarse.
Pero estábamos buscando
en el lugar equivocado.
Y esto pasa cuando las tareas y los
análisis sobrevaloran alguna métrica
—en este caso, la comunicación verbal—
y devalúan otras,
cómo la resolución creativa de problemas.
La comunicación era difícil para Isaac,
así que encontró una alternativa
para encontrar lo que necesitaba saber.
Al pensarlo, tiene mucho sentido,
porque hacer una pregunta
es un proceso muy complejo,
pero él pudo evitar mucho de eso
poniendo una palabra en el buscador.
Y ese pequeño momento
tuvo un profundo impacto en mí
y nuestra familia
porque nos ayudó a cambiar
el marco de referencia
sobre lo que le pasaba a él,
y preocuparnos menos y apreciar más
su forma de obtener recursos.
Los hechos son cosas estúpidas.
Y se pueden usar mal,
manipular u otras cosas.
Tengo una amiga, Emily Willinghan
que es científica,
y escribió un artículo para Forbes
no hace mucho,
titulado "Las 10 cosas más raras
ligadas al Autismo".
Es una buena lista
"El Internet" es culpado por todo ¿cierto?,
y claro las madres, porque sí.
Y en realidad, esperen, hay más,
un grupo completo
en la categoría de "madre" aquí.
Pueden ver que es una lista
muy rica e interesante.
Soy una gran fan de
"embarazarse cerca de autopistas".
(Risas)
La última es interesante,
porque el término "madre de refrigerador"
fue en realidad la hipótesis original
para la causa del autismo,
y se refería a una persona fría
y no amorosa.
En este momento, pueden pensar:
"Está bien, Susan, lo entendemos,
puedes tomar datos,
y hacer que signifiquen lo que sea".
Y es cierto, absolutamente cierto.
Pero el reto es que
tenemos la oportunidad
de darles significado nosotros mismos,
porque francamente,
los datos no crean un significado.
Nosotros se los damos.
Así que como personas de negocios,
como consumidores,
como pacientes, como ciudadanos,
tenemos una responsabilidad, creo,
de pasar más tiempo
enfocándonos
en nuestras capacidades críticas.
¿Por qué?
Porque en este punto de la historia,
como hemos escuchado
muchas veces,
podemos procesar exabytes de datos
a la velocidad de la luz,
y tenemos el potencial
de tomar malas decisiones
mucho más rápidamente, eficientemente,
y con mucho más impacto que en el pasado.
Genial, ¿no es cierto?
Y lo que necesitamos hacer en su lugar
es pasar un poco más de tiempo
en cosas como las humanidades
y sociología, y las ciencias sociales,
retórica, filosofía, ética,
porque nos dan el contexto
que es tan importante
para los datos masivos, y porque
nos ayudan
a volvernos mejores pensadores críticos.
Porque después de todo, si puedo ver
un problema en un argumento,
no importa mucho,
que este expresado en palabras o números.
Y esto significa
enseñarnos a nosotros mismos
a encontrar esos sesgos confirmatorios
y falsas correlaciones,
y a ser capaces de ver una afirmación
puramente emocional
desde 10 metros,
porque que algo que pase después de otra cosa
no significa que pasó por eso
necesariamente,
y si me dejan ser geek por un segundo,
los romanos lo llamaban:
"post hoc ergo propter hoc",
"después de esto, entonces por esto".
Y significa cuestionar disciplinas
como la demografía.
¿Por qué?
Porque están basadas en asumir cosas,
sobre quiénes somos con base en nuestro género
nuestra edad y dónde vivimos,
opuestos a datos de qué es lo que pensamos
y hacemos en realidad.
Y dado que tenemos estos datos,
necesitamos tratarlos con adecuados
controles de privacidad
y al consumir optar por inclusión,
y más allá de eso necesitamos ser claros
en nuestras hipótesis,
las metodologías que usamos,
y nuestro nivel de confianza en el resultado.
Cómo decía mi maestro de álgebra:
"muestra tus matemáticas,
porque si no sé qué pasos usaste,
no sé qué pasos no tomaste,
y si no sé qué preguntas hiciste,
no sé qué preguntas no hiciste".
Significa preguntarnos a nosotros mismos,
la pregunta más difícil de todas:
¿Los datos en realidad nos lo muestran,
o el resultado nos hace sentir
más exitosos y más cómodos?
Así que los de Colaboración por la Salud en Medios
al final del proyecto, pudieron
encontrar 87 % de tweets
sobre esos muy gráficos y perturbadores
anuncios para dejar de fumar
que expresaban miedo,
pero ¿concluyeron que hicieron
que la gente dejara de fumar?
No. Es ciencia, no magia.
Así que si vamos a abrir
el poder de los datos,
no tenemos que ir a ciegas en la visión
de Orwell de un futuro totalitario,
o la visión de Huxley de uno trivial,
o un horrible cóctel de ambos.
Lo que tenemos que hacer es tratar
al pensamiento crítico con respeto
y ser inspirados por ejemplos
cómo el de Colaboración por la Salud en Medios
y como dicen
en las películas de superhéroes:
"Usemos nuestros poderes para el bien".
Gracias.
(Aplausos)